ja ihr habt es sicher mitbekommen obwohl
der hurricanes auf die niedrigste stufe
herabgesetzt wurde waren seine
auswirkungen dramatisch und es gibt
mehrere gründe die florence so besonders
gefährlich gemacht haben welcher sind
und was die globale erderwärmung damit
zu tun hat das alles und noch viel mehr
jetzt bei bigsim science fiction
herzlich willkommen zuletzt hatten die
us-behörden florence zwar noch
herabgestuft doch die gefahr ist noch
lange nicht gebannt extreme sturmfluten
und regen bender die sich tagelang über
dem land ergießen werden
der deutsche astronaut alexander gerst
hat von der raumstation iss wirklich
krasse fotos vom voraus gemacht dazu
seine eindringliche warnung per twitter
an die usa watch out amerika also sowas
wie aufgepasst amerika und es gibt
tatsächlich einige aspekte die diesen
hurrikan zu einem ungewöhnlichen sturm
gemacht haben und zu einer tödlichen
gefahr außerdem 17 menschen sind
gestorben und ganze ortschaften werden
wohl noch in der folge ausradiert
dennoch immer bahn sich das wasser
seinen weg ins landesinnere und das hat
vor allem mit dem klimawandel zu tun zum
einen hat der florence die möglichkeit
nahe der küste noch einmal so richtig
aufzuladen den hurricanes bekommen ihre
energie aus dem warmen ozean der
mindestens 27 grad celsius warm ist
derzeit ist das wasser an der küste an
die 30 grad warm dass es mehr als
normalerweise um diese zeit das hat
florence noch einmal so richtig gepusht
dazu kommt er bringt gigantische
regenmengen mit sich durch den
klimawandel sind es laut aktuellen
analysen 50 prozent mehr regen und der
niederschlag den hurricanes mit sich
bringen stellt sich meist noch einmal
als viel dramatischer heraus als der
wind selbst das haben wir auch 2017 bhw
gesehen der houston unter wasser gesetzt
hat der flüsse treten über die ufer
wasser und schlamm strömen dann die
hügel herab an den bergen der
us-ostküste ist viel feuchtigkeit ab
geregnet unmengen an wasser in form von
sturzfluten suchen sogar das
landesinnere ein gemälde zum beispiel
die ortschaft feiert will land unter und
sie ist 150 kilometer von der küste
entfernt und die tatsache dass es in
vielen regionen der ostküste schon in
der letzten zeit sehr viel geregnet hat
macht das nicht besser im gegenteil denn
der grundwasserspiegel ist hoch und
böden sowieso schon sehr nass das führt
dazu dass das regenwasser nicht im boden
versickern kann
was die überschwemmung verstärkt schon
alexander gerst hat er festgestellt dass
es sich bei florence um einen sehr
großen jährigen handelt der den regen
wohl über eine ungewöhnlich große region
bringen wird sein durchmesser lag bei
etwa 800 kilometern fachleute warnen
deswegen vor überschwemmungen in fast
allen regionen von south und north
carolina
das ist insgesamt ein gebiet das größer
ist als großbritannien und der hurrikan
ist nicht nur groß sondern auch langsam
seine geringe geschwindigkeit hat
zweierlei auswirkungen zum einen hat der
länger feuchtigkeit aus dem meer aufs
land gebracht und zum anderen ist er
auch über einen längeren zeitraum ab
geregnet und auch das ist eine folge des
klimawandels wie ein forschungsteam in
einer analyse im fachmagazin nature
festgehalten hat besonders große sorge
bereitet den menschen in north carolina
übrigens die tierhaltung industrie auf
den punkt gebracht lautet die große
frage wohin mit der ganzen schweine
scheiße
denn mehr als 2000 fahren produzieren
eine gigantische menge an gülle die
lediglich in offenen gruben gelagert
wird durch die überschwemmungen könnten
krankheitserreger so sogar ins
grundwasser gelangen und das trinkwasser
verseuchen ganz abgesehen davon dass die
fäkalien mit großer sicherheit früher
oder später in flüsse seen und ins meer
gelangen dabei steht schon länger fest
dass diese region enorm vom klimawandel
betroffen ist 2011 kam eine kommission
zu dem ergebnis dass der meeresspiegel
an der küste north carolinas um einen
meter steigen könnte und das bis zum
ende des 21 jahrhunderts derzeit sind es
knapp ist es knapp 1 cm pro jahr und das
nur am rande
klimaforscher melden sich angesichts der
aktuellen situation zu wort und warnen
vor einer weiteren globalen katastrophe
so wie etwa der wissenschaftler stefan
rahmstorf aus potsdam
zitat die globale erwärmung hat
auswirkungen auf tropische stürme und
das maß der von ihnen verursachten
schäden heißt also im klartext die
intensität solcher stürme könnte durch
wärmere meerestemperaturen weiter
steigen und wir machen weiter hierbei
klicks um ihr können tricks und jetzt
weiter werbefrei machen wir haben schon
angefangen ab sofort gibt es jeden
hat ein video ohne prolls dank eurer
hilfe immer wenn wir entsprechend viele
kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten
wir die werbung abwehr wird also
mitglied hier unter dem video
draufklicken und ihr bekommt noch
exklusive extra videos live streams und
noch ein paar weitere privilegien wenn
er immer garantiert über aktuelle videos
informiert werden wollt dann hättet mich
übrigens bei whatsapp dann bekommt ihr
den link zum video vor allen andern von
mir persönlich auf euer handy einfach
hier draufklicken und da drunter geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
klimawandel bestätigt skeptiker
endgültig widerlegt bis dann bleibt dran